Clinton world and their enemies within
the Democratic Party are engaged in kind
of a family feud about whether or not
they should relitigate Bill Clinton's
past this is what Josh barro of Business
Insider titled his piece today the
Clintons held the Democratic Party
hostage for two decades going on to
right inside the core problem is that
the Democrats decided the Clintons were
their people and then reasoned backward
to their principles so I'm a question is
it fair to argue that the GOP treated
the bushes the same way and that
President Trump has wrestled the party
back to its Reagan roots joining us now
from Washington is Ronald Reagan
biographer extraordinaire Craig Shirley
and from Austin Texas mark up Grove he's
the author of the new book the last
Republicans inside the extraordinary
relationship between George HW Bush and
George W Bush it's great to see both of
you like let's start with you Craig on
this question of the the legacy of the
bushes in the camp obviously the bushes
didn't have their you know sexual
scandals other than they I guess the
groping from the wheelchair rumor that
we're hearing now but they have their
sexual scandals but nevertheless there
was a there's clearly a break that has
happened for the most part from the
bushes to the current Republican Party
talk about that
well the bushes were always Laura an
aberration to some degree look at George
HW Bush was only president because he
was Ronald Reagan's vice president for
two terms and and back to New York Times
poll in 1988 after he beat Michael
Dukakis said that a majority of
Americans voted him because they saw him
as a continuation of the Reagan legacy
obviously he didn't continue that and he
pursued you know basically big
government republicanism as did his son
george w bush so they're both the
aberrations from the through the degree
of the republican party is that the
parties always traditionally been at
least in the modern era for less
government more freedom you know
federalism all those issues that Anna
Mae Republicans centered on the
principle of personal freedom dignity
and right so they were
so there was kind of a natural exorcism
that had to happen because they both
ended up as perceived as failed
presidencies in mark George W Bush whom
I liked very much personally he left
office with an abysmal approval rating
it was in the mid 20s by most accounts
the nation had turned against pretty
much both wars in the Middle East we had
the mass economic collapse he tried to
push through immigration amnesty that
went down in flames Harriet Miers the
Supreme Court had to pull that back we
lost the house we lost the Senate and
then we lost the presidency to Barack H
Obama yet in your book you kind of make
this argument that the bushes are the
real Republicans and they're worried
that they're gonna that Trump will be
the last Republican because he's not
really a Republican I find that that
analysis curious given the carnage post
Bush to the Republican Party well I want
to be clear that when I call them the
last Republicans that that's really a
type of establishment republicanism that
the Republican electorate clearly
rejected in the 2016 campaign cycle to
the surprise of everybody and I think to
a large extent the Republican Party
wanted to protect the establishment in
the beginning of the cycle they resisted
the candidacy of Donald Trump he won the
nomination fair and square
and went on to win the the presidency so
there's no disputing that but it is the
end of a kind of republished
republicanism where America was more
engaged in the world
morgy wait wait hold on a sec the
president just came back from this 12
day trip to Asia he was in the
Philippines Vietnam Korea China at the
APEC summit he went to Europe talked
about NATO he went to he went to talk to
all the Muslim leaders he went to
Jerusalem he went to meet the Pope I
mean he's he's he's been around and he
wants to engage for the rest of the
world he just doesn't want us to be
involved in endless wars which in part
helped elect Barack Obama so the idea
that he's some isolationist that's
ridiculous I that is such a bush line
that oh he's an isolationist he's a
protectionist he's a nativist those are
those old
just aren't working anymore mark and I
think the more we hear them the more
people just start laughing when they
hear them well I think that if you look
at the the the Trump agenda it was
largely transactional it was what what
deal can we get that's the best deal for
America and that's fine
I think the bushes were pushing a
different kind of agenda humanitarian
agenda so that's a globalist Asia tour
well that's the terminals markets yeah
sure yeah that's the turret range crab
again that's a very different kind of
republicanism yeah well yeah well it's a
focusing on America first I want to play
a sound bite from 1979 this is 1981
actually from Ronald Reagan for both of
you and have you quickly react let's
watch it is my intention to curb the
size and influence of the federal
establishment and a demand recognition
of the distinction between the powers
granted to the federal government and
those reserved to the States or to the
people
all of us all of us need to be reminded
that the federal government did not
create the states the states created the
federal government Craig I watched that
from 1981 until girl and I stood stood
at the president's grave tonight I said
a prayer for him and Nancy and thanked
him for what he did to that for this
country I watched that and I wonder what
would he think today about the state of
the Republican Party in the state of
this country well he was always a party
man once he switched parties he would he
supported Republicans even those he
didn't always agree with but you know
that sound byte reminds me of how Reagan
was such a devotee of the Constitution
the Declaration he was he started out as
a became a child the Enlightenment
believing that that the the man was more
important than the state and that
statement about the state's
creating the federal government that's
right out of the Federalist Papers it's
right out of Madison which he avidly
read he was he was a American
conservative he believed that power
flowed upward from the people to the
national government as opposed to say
like a British conservative who believes
that power flows down from the
institutions to the individual he was
very centered on the rights and dignity
and privacy of the American individual
hey Mark do you think Ronald Reagan
would tweet if he was alive during
Twitter didn't kid tweet
nobody would disagree well I'll make my
point and then Mark no I don't think he
what Reagan was really about civility
and when he went to Washington he
campaigned against a big government but
government actually got bigger during
the Reagan administration there were
three platforms he campaigned on one it
was ending the the Cold War by a clear
American victory which he achieved
largely or helped to achieve
he wanted to end big government
government got bigger and he wanted to
restore the American Americans pry out
of time but he would have tweeted he
would have tweeted Craig why because he
knew that was the peanut because
love technology he mastered commercial
radio in the 30s he mastered movies in
the 40s he mastered television in the
50s the 60s
he loved technology they loved the
ability to communicate his message wide
his audience but he would have tweeted
it was alive today he would he'd be
using Facebook and he'd be using Twitter
yes just like Trump's tweets yeah it
would be did tweet and would all love
the tweets let's face it great to have
you both on thank you so much